Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192. David P Here is a very
important and powerful reaction
to the arrest of Donald Trump.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: What about
Hillary's emails? All right, Thanks. Bye.
Speaker 1: I know that this is tongue in cheek,
in all seriousness. What a backfire. What about
Hillary was the criminal and Biden's a criminal
and Obama is a criminal and Trump is not a
criminal. And yet Trump is the one who is getting
arrested and indicted at least once, if not many,
many more times as we might see in the next 6 to
8 weeks. What about Hillary's emails? That is a
really great question. We have a fantastic bonus
show for you today quietly. Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis has legalized permit less concealed carry
in Florida. What? Yes. Secondly, we are at a
16 year high in traffic deaths. Why? We will
discuss. And thirdly, Paris is banning those
electric rental scooters. I actually have a lot
to say about this and the whole rental scooter
thing in general. So we're going to talk about
all of that on today's bonus show. Get instant
access by signing up at join Pacman dot com.